[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في ظل التوتر الشديد
والمتصاعد بين الولايات المتحده والصين
وافقت واشنطن على بيع ذخائر لتايوان وفق
اعلان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه واعلن
البنتاغون ان واشنطن قد صادقت على بيع
ذخائر بقيمه 619 مليون دولار لتايوان
مخصصه لطائراتها المقاتله من طراز اف 16
واكد البنتاجون ان هذه الصفقه ستعزز قدره
تايوان على ضمان الدفاع عن مجالها الجوي
وعن الامن الاقليمي والتوافق في العمليات
مع الولايات المتحده من جهتها اكدت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان عمليه بيع الاسلحه
مطابقه للموقف الامريكي التقليدي حيال
بكين
واعربت الحكومه التايوانيه عن ارتياحها
لصفقه الاسلحه الاولى التي تعلنها
الولايات المتحده هذه السنه والتاسعه في
عهد الرئيس جو بايدن يذكر انه قبل ايام من
اعلان الصفقه هدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
وطني باستهداف الشركات والافراد الصينيين
بعقوبات اذا ما انتهكت بكين العقوبات
الامريكيه ومده روسيا بالاسلحه في ظل
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بكينا اتهمت
واشنطن في اكثر من مناسبه بزواجيه
المعايير في تعاملها مع الملفات الدوليه
فكيف سيكون رد الصيني على صفقه التسليح
الاخيره
امريكيه للتايوان بقيمه 619 مليون دولار
الصفقه تضم 100 صاروخ عالي السرعه مضاد
للرادارات من طراز اي جي ام 88
وتضم 200 صاروخ جو جو متوسط المدى متطور
من طراز اي اي ام 120 فضلا عن قاذفات
صواريخ وصواريخ تدريب
الخارجيه الامريكيه دعمنا لتايوان
والتدابير التي اتخذتها لتعزيز قدراتها
الدفاعيه تساهم في الحفاظ على الاستقرار
في مضيق تايوان والمنطقه
الخارجيه التايوانيه بمواجهه التوسع
العسكري المتواصل وسلوك الصين الاستفزازي
ستواصل
قدراتها على الدفاع الذاتي بصوره النشطه
موقف الصين بكين اتهمت واشنطن مرارا
بازدواجيه المعايير وحضرتها من دعم تايب
عسكريه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياض
الهامليه صحف الصيني اهلا بك ومن واشنطن
عبر سكايب الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
شؤون السياسيه الامريكيه اهلا بكم ماذا
الكريمين واسمح لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك
دكتور عقيل دكتور عقيل في الواقع المتابع
لتصريحات وحتى مواقف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ويرى كيف واشنطن تسلح في
المقابل هي تحذر الصين من تسليح روسيا
الخلاصه او ما يقراه البعض هو تباين هل
توافق ذلك حتى الصين اكدت على انه تباين
وازدواجيه في المعايير ان كان كذلك ما
التفسير
شكرا لك على هذا
الكريم من الرياض
اعتقد التصويرك للامر صحيح باستثناء يعني
القول انه متناقض هناك دعم امريكي يعني
هذا الموضوع يعود من 1949
ويعني
انقسام الصين الى الصين الشعبيه والتايوان
يعني التايوان الحاليه نهايه الحرب
الاهليه الذي ينظم العلاقات الامريكيه او
الموقف الاميركي باتجاه تايوان والصين هم
حقيقه قانونان قانون علاقات مع التايوان
1979 وفيه تعهدت الولايات 1988 عفوا تعهدت
في الولايات المتحده
ان تساعد على الدفاع عن نفسها
والقانون الاخر هو مرر خلال الاشهر
الاخيره في شهر ديسمبر ما يسمى قانون دعم
صمود تايوان موقف الامريكي وهذا القانون
الثاني اضاف الى الموقف الاميركي في
السابق هناك ما يسمى
الغموض الاستراتيجي الولايات المتحده لا
تقول بشكل واضح هل ترسل قواتها الى تايوان
ام لا في حال حدوث غزو صيني او شيء من هذا
القبيل الان اشارت الولايات المتحده ضمن
هذا القانون الذي مرر سريعا هو جزئيا كرد
فعل على السلوك الصيني بعد زياره نانسي
بلوسي رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي في شهر
ابريل وما بدا يعني التحركات عسكريه صينيه
واستفزازات صينيه هذا القانون يقول انه هو
التايوان هي حليف رئيسي ميجر لكنه ليس من
جماعه
واشنطن
ومدى سعي واشنطن للدفاع ولحمايه ولكن
السؤال مطروح هو في المقابل لماذا تح رم
الصين من مساعده روسيا
وان كانت الصين تنفي بانها قدمت اسلحه
ولكن ان كان هناك امكانيه لذلك لماذا
واشنطن تحذرها بعقوبات فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع
العقوبات التي فرضت الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي هي عقوبات سياديه من حق
الدول فرضها
هذه ليست عقوبات دوليه بمعنى اذ تعاملتم
مع روسيا ستخسرون تعاملكم الاقتصادي معنا
نحن في حاله حرب غير معلنه مع روسيا الغرب
عمليا بسبب العدوان الروسي الواضح على
اوكرانيا
ربما نقرا راي اخر استاذ الهام ما قولك
فيما يتفضل به ضيفي هو يقول بانه هذه
العقوبات عقوبات مشروعه هي ليست عقوبات
ولي هي عقوبات سياديه ومن حق واشنطن ان
تطرح هذه العقوبات اذا رات بانه الحسابات
لا تتوافق مع حساباتها يعني حسابات الغير
لا تتوافق ولا تتماشى مع حسبتها هي
نعم اول شيء شكرا جزيلا لدعوتكم الكريمه
في الحقيقه يعني نعم
قيل ان هذه العقوبات
السياديه ولكن في الحقيقه
الدول الغربيه وخاصه الولايات المتحده
دائما تستخدم الهيمنه
لاجباره الدول الاخرى
اتخاذ العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا او على
دوله معينه مثلا يعني عند الولايات
المتحده نظام سويفت وهذا النظام متمسك
بايدي الولايات المتحده لذلك يعني اذا
استخدم الولايات المتحده هذا النظام يكون
هناك عقوبات دوليه في الحقيقه يعني لا
يمكن ان نقارن مع
عقوبات السياديه الامريكيه او عقوباتها
سياديه من دول الافريقيه وبالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني اذا نقارن مع العقوبات من الصين
تجاه الشركات العسكريه
الامريكيه مثل حقيقه يعني عقوبات من جانب
الصين هذا بكل المعنى العقوبات السياديه
يعني تتخذ الصين السياسه او القوانين
الصينيه لمنع بدخول الماسورين بهذه
الشركات الى الصين وايضا لاجراء الاعمال
التجاريه في الصين وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني
نتخيل اذا الصين تقدم الاسلحه للانفصاليين
من ولايه معينه من الولايات المتحده مثلا
الذين يدعمون بانفصال ولايه الكاليفورنيا
من الولايات المتحده او ولايه تكساس من
الولايات المتحده فما العمل بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده فيعني هناك لا مجال
للمقارنه بين اوكرانيا
وقضيه التايوان ففي الحقيقه اوكرانيا دوله
صياديه ولكن قضيه حيوان هذه قضيه يعني
داخليه بالنسبه لحكومه الصينيه وبالاضافه
الى ذلك يعني في الحقيقه تقديم الاسلحه
حمايه او ارتفاع
وكما هو تقديم الاصلي لدعم الانفصاليين من
الجزيره تايوان الصينيه وبالاضافه الى ذلك
يعني كان هناك تصريحه بشكل واضح من قبل
وزاره الدفاع الصينيه بان الصين وخصوصا
الجيش الصيني تتخذ المزيد من التحركات
لمواجهه التحديات وايضا
تلبيه او يعني اجابه عن التحركات او
تصرفات الولايات المتحده لبيع الاسلحه الى
تايوان دكتور عقيل ما رايك حضرتك منذ قليل
تحدثت عن عقوبات سياديه ضيفي كما استمعت
لا يقول لك هي سياديه ولكن تداعياتها مثلا
نظام السويف نظام امريكي ولكن واشنطن تحكم
قبضتها عليه ولما فرضت هذه العقوبات على
روسيا مثلا تضرر العالم فسؤال مطروح هل
واشنطن يمكن ان تفرض عقوبات جديده على
الصين يمكن ان تكون تداعيات هذه العقوبات
الدوليه من جديد وان تحدث خللا اضافيا على
النظام الاقتصادي العالمي
يعني العقوبات الاقتصاديه السياديه
بالمناسبه الصين ايضا تفرض عقوبات
اقتصاديه على تايوان يعني ليست فقط
الولايات المتحده في العاده العقوبات
الاقتصاديه تعكس قوه الدوله وقدرتها
والولايات المتحده قوه اقتصاديه هائله في
اخر المطاف عندما تقول لن نتعامل مع الصين
اذا فعلت كذا وكذا مع شركاتها هي تتصرف في
اطار حقها القانوني لا يمكن ان تمنعنا
املك اموالا واقول انا لا
اتعاطى بهذه الاموال مع هذا الطرف اذا قام
بذلك بامكانها ان يذهب ويتعاطى مع اطراف
اخرى الاطار القانوني صحيح هل لهذه
تاثيرات دوليه طبعا لها تاثيرات دوليه مثل
غزو بلد اخر له تاثيرات دوليه مثل منع
تصدير القمح والحبوب الى دول تحتاجها كما
تفعل روسيا له تاثيرات دوليه مثل قيام دول
بتطوير سلاح نووي كما تفعل ايران له
تاثيرات دوليه كل الاشياء لها تا الدوليه
لكن علينا ان نقرر هل اي تاثير نقف ضده
واي تاثير يمكن ان نتفاوض معه
عقيل اسمح لي لما تتحدث عن يعني ملف غزو
دوله وتقول بانه واشنطن من حقها ان تفرض
عقوباتها ضيف منذ قليل يقول لك بانه وضع
مغير تماما والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لطالما كانت في تصريحاتها تقر بالصين
الواحده
لا يمكن مقارنه اوكرانيا روسيا الحرب
الحاليه بما تشهده علاقه
من يعني تشنج هذه المرحله
وبالتالي هل ستمضي واشنطن في تسليح حتى
بهذه الظروف او بهذه الخطوط العريضه لهذا
الوضع
طبعا صحيح لا يمكن مقارنه اوكرانيا
بتايوان لكن المقارنه هذه الصينيه ليست
امريكيه الموقف الاميركي واضح وهو انه
تايوان جزء من الصين لكن عودتها الى الصين
ينبغي ان تكون بموافقه التايوانيين لا
يمكن القيام بهذا بالسلاح هذا هو الموقف
الاميركي مثل اوكرانيا وافقت على ان تدخل
لديها القوات الروسيه وان تصبح جزءا من
روسيا هذا قرار اوكراني ذات الامر ينطبق
على تايوان الرفض الاميركي هو لاستخدام
السلاح لفرض
التوحيد الصين كما يحدث ولايه كاليفورنيا
في الولايات المتحده صوتت وقررت ان تنفصل
على الولايات المتحده هذا من
حقها القانوني اعتقد هناك سوء فهم كبير
السياق اوسع وليس قانونيه في واقع الامر
سياق الاوسع نحن نتحدث عن صراع سياسي
جيوبوليتيكي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
واحده من اهم محطات هذا الصراع هو تايوان
الصين دائما تريد ان تختبر الولايات
المتحده
والتزامها بقضيه تايوان والدفاع عن تايوان
وهذه حصلت يعني على مدى العقد الماضي خمس
او سته مرات في اللحظات التي صحيح حضرتك
تعتبر بان الصين تود ان تختبر بكين
واشنطن ولكن البعض يقول بان العكس يقول
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من خلال
مثلا زياره الاخيره من خلال مات لها من
زيارات من خلال تصريحاتها المتكرره عن
تسليح هي التي تجس نبض ما رايك سيد الهام
يعني خليني انقل فقط النقطه واعود لك
دكتور
نعم في الحقيقه يعني عندما نتكلم عن
العقوبات المفروضه من قبل دوله قويه جدا
الى دوله يعني قعده فيعني اعتقد هذا من
مبادئ او قوانين الغابه يعني من حق الدوله
قويه ان يفرد اي نوع من العقوبات على دوله
معينه ويعني من واجبي للدوله التعريفه ان
يتحمل بكل تداعيات فهذا غير
الصين ضعيفه نعم
ليس الصين ضعيفه ولكن يعني الولايات
المتحده دائما تستخدم هذه العقوبات لاجبار
الدول معينه
لاقناعها وفي الحقيقه يعني بالاضافه الى
القوه الاقتصاديه ممكن نقول يعني الصين
والولايات المتحده في نفس المستوى ولكن
عندما نجارن بتسدير الاسلحه في الحقيقه
الصيني والولايات المتحده ليس في نفس
المستوى وبعيده جدا من
المتحده يعني صحيح ولكن يقول الامريكان
واعذرني على المقاطعه بان كل ما تفضلت به
هذا وجهه نظر الصينيه الواقع الامريكي
يقول بان للولايات المتحده الامريكيه مطلق
الحريه في الدفاع اولا على مصالحها في
ترتيب حساباتها بما يتناسب مع ما تطلبه هي
من المجتمع الدولي السؤال يبقى مطروح كيف
سيكون موقف بكين ان دعمت فعليا واشنطن
بالمزيد من السلاح
نعم في الحقيقه يعني الصين تتمسك بمبدا
واضحه جدا بان الصيني لا تستخدم القوه
العسكريه في يعني
الا ان تعلن السلطات التايوانيه
بالاستقلال او بالانفصال هذا مبدا الاساسي
ولكن في نفس الوقت يعني اذا واصلت
الولايات المتحده لبيع الاسلحه في الحقيقه
وهناك بعض الاسلحه للدفاع وايضا هناك بعض
الاسلحه اسلحه للهجمات وخاصه يعني مع
زياره الناس فلوسي الى جزيره تايوان نكون
هناك المزيد من التحركات الدبلوماسيه
والحكوميه الامريكيه لدعم
الانفصال الحقيقي لجزيره تايوان من الصين
وعلى فكره يعني انا اريد الى ان اشير نقطه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه الى
قضيه تايوان فكما قال اتيتنا من الولايات
المتحده بان قضيه من اللازمه يكون هناك
موافقه لكن ليس فقط الموافقه لتايوانيين
فقط بل لجميع الصينيين وهذا يعني
نفس الوضع بالنسبه الى الازمه الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيه لازم يكون هناك موافقه
فلذلك
سوء فهم او سوق سوء تقدير من الجهتين على
كل سنبقى في متابعه دائما لكل هذه
التفاصيل شكرا جزيلا لكم على المشاركه من
الرياض الهامليه صحف الصيني ومن واشنطن
دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤون السياسيه
الامريكيه شكرا لكم